hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for Annika and sorry I'm
doing the intro really fast and [ __ ] I
did it before but the game didn't count
because I took it from my webcam is Mike
and I don't have a mic on the webcam so
it doesn't really make any sense
super we're playing breach and instead
of doing James June her ship boy had a
hop-on with gladiator rep 60 all that
good stuff we're gonna be taking toes
this whole game getting everybody these
woolen guys don't have [ __ ] on me
not at all yeah I'm a master tier player
and these Chinese Japanese looking guys
don't got [ __ ] on the Knights and yes
I'm going to be considered one of those
[ __ ] that plays the romaine and
we're the new characters just released
I'm playing their main very bad I
[ __ ] collect all right
they all admit they got us in the first
half but we coming back now we coming
back we're gonna be playing a little bit
of gladiator for this game probably just
probably the whole rest of this game
unless our team gets clapped but yeah
well I'll see you when uh something
interesting happens in the spin this
video since I'm basically gonna be dead
for probably half of this I was hoping
that would hit him I know I'm gonna be
needing some help from these for my
teammates here because this is not gonna
be good bit slow alright he's getting
his them green but I shall win gotta
watch out for the place I'm in a bit of
a 2v1 scenario this is not where
gladiator shines at all it's the issue
dashboard maybe I don't care if they get
to revive that's not my current issue at
the moment I just need to get this
survive for my teammates and then
knocking killed that should have been
heavy I didn't know if that was a light
attack I'm just I'm also not used to how
long their moves are like in terms of
what berries I should be using and
certain times I like what you know what
move is walk basically is what I'm at
is what I'm saying I do not their new
some night I don't know you not well
equipped - dude do the ash move again
you're dumb
get out of my face what do I say not new
[ __ ] bro c-diff alright so that is a
light attack that's interesting it
doesn't seem like it though
Oh while I was quite dam Brock quick as
that move it's gotta be like I'd say 500
milliseconds that's not I don't know the
exact frame data but it just seems like
it is that's alright though I was going
off there for a little bit that's
impressive
oh my [ __ ] Jesus Christ oh it's good
the [ __ ] out of me alright alright I
appreciate that new [ __ ] one of the
things I hope that happens is that I
hope we win this game not just because
the fact that we're gonna win that
because you know winning is good well I
have a new signature for gladiator and
if you guys haven't seen gladiators
signatures he's got a pretty good one he
kind of does basically he kind of deals
like a circle like he sit still kind of
walks off to the left and then does like
then runs back around feels like a weird
360 and then like throws his shield near
not like actually throws it for like
puts his shield up in the air kind of
thing like showing off to the crowd it
would be and I thought that was pretty
cool what his second one is crazy and
I'll show it to you now or I'll show it
to you when we win if we win I'll try to
beat two copiers if we don't win I'm
showing it to you anyway because I think
this is such a it's such a good
signature and I bought it almost
instantly I cannot wait to get the
timing down for that movie so I can
parry that I can deflect that that's
gonna be spicy because he can't follow
up after that I think he can but I don't
think I didn't you care too much
it isn't a freebie wanna give me old
toes man
you mean that always come here come here
one more I mean you get him yeah
perfect good stuff taking people's toes
men stabbing everybody let's go no one's
safe from me you know third and the only
person that's I'm picking me is a bot
cuz I'm brilliant playing the wrong game
mode for this character go toes mine
yo toes again my good stuff Shaolin I
must say though the graphical
enhancements on this or making this map
and just everything look crazy good like
gladiator looks like an absolute tank
and just the sulfuric sparks just makes
this way better with the more darkish
tone instead of having a like a brighter
look and I'm about to get 3v1
alright [ __ ] that bye bye no that ain't
it chief no ice to bed we're all dead
great plan so now we have 22 lives to
kill this ward I have pretty good
confidence Oh work what a crazy counter
about that's called but is like kind of
the crush encounter as usual in last
place and I [ __ ] spawned into a Jang
Joon your buddy winds up in my spawn
right now get out of my face
steel your toes for you cuz you're doing
that
Oh perfect set up my stuff bought me in
taquito here oh oh that's why we got
spawn camps because they're right there
all right well since no one's really
watching this Lord I'll go in and kill
him oh [ __ ] me never mind me there's
also a white beserker this is also why
glided er really isn't good for this
game-mode because he he doesn't really
have
he's got good heavies of course it's a
solid 35 I think it's a solid 30 damage
which isn't like something to [ __ ]
about but like on that good fight uh-huh
but yes solid damage at 30 like a 30
damage heavies not bad but it's the fact
that he only has to cut well one it's
not as good as other characters and it's
the fact that he only has two in his
chain and you can't follow up with a
quick light attack afterwards so
characters like T on me do crazy damage
I think James used like immense as well
like really good characters that have
really good high damage like Rader with
his own
I'm already drawing blanks on names here
I think berserkers top-heavy would be
nice the crush encounter from warden but
I mean I but you know stuff like that
big attacks really help against this war
the Lord and I just don't think
gladiator fits in that category it just
doesn't have like crazy moves that are
like immensely powerful like I just did
I can do 60 damage if I land it which
isn't bad like it's basically one hell
it's basically one tick of health which
ain't bad so I'm not bitching but I feel
like there's way better options for this
game-mode I would definitely say
gladiator sadly is not going to be
viable if he and if he is Sam if he is
he's not going to be as good of a pick
for this game are for breach mode which
sucks so that's that's the only issue I
have with him so I'm most likely will be
playing him still in breach but I'm
probably not gonna perform as good as I
would hope it's going to be a little bit
of a struggle
damn house feeding we're getting really
close now all of us are dead so that
means we have now four lives once all of
us respawn the commander's health is
about I would say three heavy attacks of
a gladiator away maybe four so I'm
probably just gonna rush the [ __ ] out of
him we do have most of our teammates up
now one of them is waiting to respawn
still he's probably want to group up
with me maybe or he's not here I think
the main issue is that we didn't get the
archer point you've seen the top left
over there on point eight we did not
even grab it so that is really hindering
us with these minions and that's also
giving us extra damage so no one's even
watching this boss so his berserker just
gonna go apeshit real quick kill this
Lord and the game give me them toes game
over I want them toes and now we get to
see the the glorious signature I was
talking about a little bow and get you
eight give him a little kiss the crowd
my beautiful love that signature man
totally worth the five case deal let's
go dude you're gonna fight yeah guys
that's gonna be the end of it eh
hopefully guys didn't enjoy I wanted to
show off the new signature also playing
as you know my main in the new breach
mode I also want to put them in the hero
area because I think gladiator looks
spectacular in this section of the game
the hero section as opposed to from last
season where you know cuz these huge
graphical changes came in I actually
love the way that all the armor gets
shiny and stuff like that love it
it's everything about this update is so
good except the fact that I kind of
don't really queue up in a breach as
often as I'd like to sometimes the game
freezes sometimes it crashes sometimes
guys name it start but then there's the
time like this match where you actually
end up playing it which is nice big I
just like the view if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I'll cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes leaks and all that good
stuff you guys want me to see more
videos like this I kind of relate this
to Jeff a very popular phase youtuber he
basically just plays a couple games
shows the highlights of and
the video I'd love to do stuff like this
in the future if you guys are totally
down basically like this structure video
maybe a few edits that here and there
but we'll get to that yeah guys
hopefully guys did enjoy like I said my
two most recent videos would be on
screening if you guys do want to check
that out with that guys survived Craster
day thank you for watching the video and
peace out
[Music]